you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
our restoring peatland could be the
answer to reducing flooding from
britain's longest river
wasps are taking on bees for the title
of climate superheroes
as new research suggests they could
contribute just as much to ecosystems
[Applause]
and conservation charity wwf celebrates
60 years of fighting for nature
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come and here on our data dashboard we
can see
how much human activity has warmed our
world since the industrial revolution
and you can see it's ticking up every
second and as the planet warms we'll see
more extreme weather events
and a greater risk of flooding and
that's because put simply
a warmer atmosphere holds more moisture
and that means heavier rainfall
and an increase in river flows and
floods
and climate change projections suggest
that flood severity
is likely to increase in the future in
the uk
so finding ways to help reduce the risk
of flooding is really important
especially for rivers
such as the seven well some of the worst
floods in
living memory have hit communities along
the seven in england
in recent years a possible solution
could involve changes to the landscape
at the river's source
in wales sky's becky johnson has been
finding out how peatland could hold the
answer
to find the source of britain's longest
river
you have to head into the uplands of mid
wales
so here we are this is it this is
the source wow of the mighty river seven
all around you can see the peat that
once covered this landscape
is eroding and exists only in clumps
not enough to absorb rain and stop it
running straight into the river
when it pours the effect on communities
downstream
is devastating now an ambitious plan
from the montgomery show wildlife trust
aims to hold the water at its source by
restoring the peatland
across large parts of mid wales we're
used to the idea that farmers produce
crops
but actually i would argue that the
flood water here
could be a crop why don't the farmers
get a payment
to store that water within the peat
for the plan to work farmers would need
to be persuaded
to leave behind generations of
traditional welsh hill farming
i think it's responsibility of
government now to help farmers
you know say well this is the land that
you drained so we could have more sheep
in the 70s and 80s
well now we need you to block it all up
and revert it back
to being bog again subsidizing farmers
to give up their flocks
would cost money and the question is who
should pay for it
when the work needs to be done here in
wales but the benefits would be
primarily felt by the communities that
flood further down the river
in england and that's the sticking point
so far neither the welsh nor uk
government has committed to funding the
project
those who backed the plan say it would
cost a fraction of dealing with future
flooding
which could be a consequence of the
changing climate
becky johnson sky news
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and germany
must update its climate law by the end
of next year
as it violates young people's freedoms
the country's highest court has ruled
the government's climate policies are
insufficient as they don't give enough
detail on cutting emissions beyond
2030. it said the current law means any
reductions made after this point
will have to be achieved more urgently
[Applause]
a record three million new electric cars
were registered around the world
last year that's according to new
research from the international energy
agency
it found there was a 41 increase in the
number of electric vehicles bought in
despite total car sales falling experts
say this upward trend will need to
continue
if we're going to meet our climate goals
[Applause]
household aerosols release more
polluting smog
chemicals than all the cars in the uk
latest figures show around 60 000 tons
of harmful emissions
come from products like deodorants and
air fresheners each year
double the amount from petrol cars it's
led to scientists urging people to swap
to roll-on deodorant and hair gel
to improve the uk's air quality
[Applause]
thousands of printer cartridges are
being washed up on beaches across the
world
after being lost at sea most of the
cartridges have been found along the
uk's coastlines as well as several in
cape verde
florida and the arctic circle scientists
believe the spillage from a ship's
container occurred
around 1500 kilometers off the coast of
new york
in 2014.
[Applause]
and people are being encouraged to give
the cities they live in an eco-friendly
glow-up
a report from the british ecological
society highlights how
natural measures including planting
street trees
and increasing green spaces can have a
positive impact
experts say bringing more nature into
cities improves the environment
creates green jobs and boosts people's
health
now they might be the quickest way to
ruin a summer bbq but scientists have
found that wasps
could be just as valuable as bees well
in a moment we'll hear from professor
sarian sumner who led the research but
first here's everything you need to know
about wasps in 60 seconds
[Music]
do
with me now is serene sumner professor
of behavioural ecology at university
college london's
center for biodiversity and
environmental research
welcome to you and unlike bees wasps
don't have a great reputation do they
is it time to rethink that do you think
how useful are they
oh i think you've hit on the point there
yes it is absolutely time to revisit
how we view wasps so we've we've got a
fabulous legacy
from the way that we have changed
people's perceptions
of bees and how people really appreciate
the role of bees in the environment they
understand
that they're important in the kind of
services that they provide us with which
are through pollination
but wasps on the other hand have kind of
gone slightly forgotten
um and this is surprising because
actually there's a whole there's this
decades worth of work
that does show that wasps have really
important roles in the ecosystems
so what are they i know for example
they're top predators aren't they of
other insects so why is that useful
yeah so they are predators of so they're
carnivores so if you
the wasps are the origins of of bees
actually bees evolve from wasps
um so bees are uh herbivores they don't
eat meat
um they've forgotten how to hunt and so
that's why they they're good at
pollinating but the wasps are carnivores
the adults will hunt prey
and if there are social wars they'll
bring it back to their nest feed their
brood
or if they're a solitary wasp they will
paralyze that
prey that caterpillar or fly and bury it
in the ground and lay an egg on it
so in provisioning their own offspring
they are actually providing
uh the ecosystems and and us
incidentally
with the service of controlling and
regulating insect populations so
if you like a world without wasps would
mean that there would be many
unchecked populations of other insects
that we might even find more
more um loathsome than the wasp and how
might they cope with climate change
themselves
that's a really good question um so
unfortunately unlike uh species like
bees and butterflies
um our understanding of wasp populations
is quite
limited people don't tend to record
their opposite observations of wasps
there's almost like a wasp-blindness
um but from the data that we do have
scientists have been able to gather data
for example from
um museum collections as well as some
biological records and it looks like
uh certainly some species of wasp like
the common yellowjacket wasp
is actually doing remarkably well it
seems to be relatively
resilient to anthropogenic change
professor
sirian sumner thanks very much indeed
for changing our perceptions of how we
view the wasp thank you
thank you over the past six decades the
global environmental organization
wwf has been at the center of efforts to
protect nature
pioneering innovative initiatives in
conservation and today they celebrate
their 60th anniversary
wwf's mission now includes turning
around the crisis in the climate and
nature by 2030
ensuring a future where people and
wildlife thrive they say
well tonya steele is chief executive of
wwf uk and joins me now
welcome to you how has climate change
changed the nature of conservation
well we look at climate change and
biodiversity or nature there they're two
sides of the same coin
and we know that nature does so much to
absorb so many of the damaging
impacts of a warming world and our
oceans have absorbed nearly
90 percent um of all the additional heat
that's been generated on our planet so
protecting our nature is actually
incredibly important
in our fight against climate change and
realistically we need to be restoring it
as well to put it back
so that we can meet the commitments of a
one and a half degree world in the
future
well yes and when you say a one and a
half degree world obviously the pressure
is on
to keep rises in temperatures to one and
a half degrees
what's at stake i mean wwf was set up to
protect endangered
species how at risk are they if
temperature rises
increase too much they're hugely at risk
and we've already
lost so much we've seen a average global
drop in
in wildlife population numbers of 68
in the last 50 years that is a
catastrophic loss i mean nature is in
free fall
so the prospect of losing any more
precious wildlife which
we rely on as well as its intrinsic
beauty but we rely on it for a healthy
and also for a stable planet
if we lose our nature if we lose our
wildlife then we really will not have a
stable planet
and a healthy environment for all of us
to live in the years to come
tony steele thanks very much indeed and
on our weekly climate show we're finding
out the climate impact of cryptocurrency
and hear the behind the scenes story of
how our correspondent tom cheshire
filmed at a secret bitcoin
farm in china that's available from
friday afternoons on sky news social
media channels our app
and our website and that's everything
from us for today
on the daily climate show tomorrow we go
inside the biggest wind turbine testing
facility in the world
to find out how the renewable energy
could help power the uk
to net zero thanks for watching see you
[Music]
then
you